i want to start with something a little
different today you know we pointed out
that uh both during the trump
administration
and even after his election loss during
which he became
the lame duck president that he is now
as there were
many public scandals and much media
coverage of
some aspects of what donald trump was
doing there
continued to be republicans
doing things horrible things including
of course mitch mcconnell helping to
conf
confirm extremist judges but also
rolling back environmental regulations
which allow more pollution and all sorts
of stuff the point was
while this public-facing scandal-ridden
fiasco continued
below the surface the republicans were
doing things that are really horrible
well
we have now gotten a list of the things
that donald trump is going to try to
get done hopefully without much
attention being paid
to them in the remaining seven weeks of
his presidency
and they are mostly outrageous and they
include listen to this
reinstating the death penalty via both
firing squad and the electric
chair before donald trump leaves office
and on the one hand you have much of the
developed world
which has rightly moved away from the
death penalty altogether and we've
talked about the death penalty
extensively before whether you believe
the death penalty
should be eliminated because it is
fiscally
not conservative it costs more
actually in the united states than
keeping somebody in prison for the rest
of their lives and we've talked
about why whether it's because you
believe in small government and that the
government should not be
killing people whether it's because you
believe
in the unfair way that the death penalty
is disproportionately
applied in certain cases and not in
others anyway we've had we've
adjudicated the death penalty so many
times
and many developed countries have
figured that out and have moved away
from the death penalty altogether
the united states meanwhile while some
states have moved away from the death
penalty
donald trump wants federally to rush in
the reinstatement of
electric chair and death by firing squad
executions for the death penalty
there are a whole bunch of other
proposals as well which we are going to
talk about now why
why would trump be trying to add new
ways that the government can kill people
via the death penalty why would they do
this one of the things that has slowed
down
executions over the last decade or more
in the united states
is that there are sometimes there is
sometimes
scant availability of lethal injection
drugs
so the idea is well let's move ahead
with some of these executions by adding
firing squad and electric chair as
options for how the federal government
would carry out these executions now
before we move forward i think it's
important to remind you that
most executions most debt deaths most
death penalty executions in the united
states
are done by states federal executions
are relatively rare
and so this would only change the
federal rules and to give you enough
an idea of how lopsided the numbers are
since 1977
there have been fewer than 50 federal
executions
since 1977 okay but there have been
around 1 500 execution by states so it's
extraordinarily lopsided
if trump does this it would only affect
federal executions but the point is
it would start increasing that number
more quickly i'm against the death
penalty
period um and i don't care how you're
doing it
um i am opposed to it if you're
interested in that topic it hasn't come
up on the show for probably at least a
year
you can find some of my archived clips
on the youtube channel
now other changes donald trump is trying
to rush through
in the waning days of his presidency he
wants a change at the usda
to allow faster chicken processing lines
in
slaughterhouses i don't know if you've
seen what a chicken processing line
looks like uh i think it's an
interesting thing to
uh to to understand as you all know i'm
not vegan or vegetarian
but i do think it's important to
understand what uh these mass processing
facilities look like and it chicken
processing is done
essentially on an assembly line and the
idea is to allow the assembly line to
move more quickly and
the reasons not to do that would be it
would increase the chance of errors
contamination possible errant cuts which
could spread bacteria as well as risk to
workers
but donald trump wants to allow that
donald trump wants to make some
additional rule changes
that would make it more difficult for
joe biden to quickly
undo some of the environmental
restrictions that donald trump
eliminated
and trump also trying to push through a
regulation
that would exclude transgender
individuals
from federally funded homeless shelters
which is just
vile disgusting and unnecessarily cruel
trump would also loosen water saving
standards
on shower heads now that actually came
up at a bunch of trump rallies which we
covered
leading up to the election where trump
would be moan that if joe biden were to
win
you'd have trouble flushing toilets
you'd have trouble
getting good water pressure in the
shower trump at one point even wildly
claimed that if joe biden were to win
heating and cooling indoor heating and
cooling might be eliminated you might
have none of it under joe biden which
was a completely deranged claim to
begin with and uh you know just to get
ready i have stopped using heat i want
to be ready for when biden takes over
but
i'm hoping that that one doesn't come to
pass that's a joke by the way
uh imagine what kind of a person you
have to be
to say okay i've got seven weeks my last
and final seven weeks to impact
this country what can i do in this time
and the idea that comes to you is let me
expand the ways
in which the federal government is
allowed to kill
people that's a good use of my time
when you hear trump wants to bring back
firing squads it almost sounds like a
headline
from the onion a satirical news headline
then you read the article and it is all
too real trump ignored the pandemic
since day one
but capital punishment and shower heads
are at the top of his important item
list to get done before leaving office
i would understand if the world takes a
while to forgive us
for this presidency if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video